if the enigmatic Zava struck a chord of
recognition in the third season of Ted
lasso it wasn't just his magnetic
presence the actor who plays him has
built up quite a resume over the past
decade no Ted lasso character has been
quite as inscrutable as xava modeled
after other legendary single-named
footballers of similar Brilliance in ego
the star player dazzled on the field and
brought Richmond close to the top of the
table in the Premier League only to bail
mid-season after the squad started the
struggle before a shocking departure he
puzzled his teammates with a combination
of Primadonna behavior and enigmatic
locker room quips ruffled the feathers
of teammate Jamie tartt prompted Thierry
zaro to change his name to Van Damme and
informed Sam obasania that Nigerian
cooking will change considerably West
African cuisine doesn't typically
feature a lot of avocados
not yet Zama plays a crucial thematic
role in season 3 of Ted lasso Maximilian
osinski who plays the mononymous
footballer told vulture I think he was
brought on as this foil to show the team
that they can't lean on one individual
they have to work together his decision
to suddenly retire from football and
without even informing Ted has thrown a
wrench into Richmond's already
malfunctioning gears most likely the
sudden retirement is not the last we've
heard from Sava especially considering
how heavily he was schmoozing with
Rupert Mania owner of Richmond's sworn
enemy West Ham United so where may you
see no sinski before well how about the
MCU Shield agent James Davis played by
osinski First shows up in the ninth
episode of Agents of Shield isn't seen
again until the fourth season when he
becomes a recurring character he had
left shield in the interim but rejoins
under Agent Phil coulson's leadership
proving himself to be a loyal agent he's
killed in the final season after being
possessed by the malevolent entity Isel
I did warn you
could be worse in the midst of his run
as a secret agent osinski took to the
waves on TNT's The Last Ship set in a
world in which a virus has wiped out 80
percent of the global population the
show zoomed in on a crew of just 218
aboard a single U.S Navy ship at Sea USS
Nathan James saddled with the job of
finding a cure even among that small
crew osinski's Lookout Derek Evans
wasn't seen more than a handful of times
in just three episodes he's not a
prominently featured base but a face
nonetheless notably osinski got to work
with his now wife Australian Nepalese
actor deachin lachman on both The Last
Ship and Agents of Shield osinski is
also part of the quickly expanding
Universe of AMC's The Walking Dead he
appeared in the second and final season
of The Walking Dead World Beyond as
Dennis Graham has been a fan favorite
Jennifer Hawk Malik World Beyond mostly
looks at the post zombie apocalypse
Through The Eyes of the teenage
characters nicknamed the endlings like
most adults on the show Dennis is
haunted by his past grasping for
Redemption osinski told pop culturalist
asked myself why didn't he fall to the
side and become a shell of himself with
a character like Dennis it's about
trying to figure out what a person does
or how they function while dealing with
issues of their past Dennis is a decent
man who made a grave and deadly mistake
during his time with the Civic Republic
military Silas calls him one of the few
good people who have been a part of the
CRM and Denison Hawker increasingly
disturbed by the Civic Republic's
violence against innocent people the two
even joined the end Lanes to stop the
crm's planned gas attack on Portland
after Huck dies in the explosion that
destroys the gas a mortally wounded
dentist convinces Silas to shoot him so
that the latter can come off as a hero
to the Civic Republic and continue to
undermine it
foreign
[Music]